The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today we're
going to keep talking
about boundary value problems.
We'll do that
again on Wednesday.
On Friday we'll start partial
differential equations.
And next week we'll
work with COMSOL,
which I hope you guys all have
installed on your laptops.
Please check that
you have it installed
and you can turn it on,
your licensing things
work and stuff like that.
We'll have a COMSOL tutorial
I think on Monday in class.
And you'll use that for one
of the homework problems
not immediately but coming up.
Speaking of the homework,
I received some feedback
that the homeworks
have been taking
an inordinate amount of time.
And so I've discussed this
with the other people involved
in teaching it and we
decided to drastically cut
the amount of points
given for write-ups to try
to encourage you not to
spend so much time on that.
And instead I'd really
rather you spent the time
and did the reading
instead of spending
an extra hour doing write-up.
You won't get any more
points for doing it.
So if you want--
I mean, I love
beautiful write-ups.
I'm sure the graders appreciate
the beautiful write-ups.
It's good for your
thinking to write clearly
but it's not worth many,
many hours of time.
And in general, the instructions
at the beginning of course,
are on average over the
course, your 14 weeks,
it should be about nine
hours per week of homework.
So that's maybe 13
hours per assignment,
so you have 10 assignments.
And so if it's getting
to be 15 hours,
you've spent too much time
on it and just forget it.
Just draw a line and say
I'm done, time ran out,
and that's fine.
This is-- getting the last
bug out of your Matlab code
is not the main
objective of this course.
And really, the
purpose of homework
is to help you
learn, not that we
need to know what the
solution to this problem is.
This is now--
I'm getting the solution from
somebody else in the class
too so this is--
I don't need it from you.
The TAs probably
already did it already
and they have the solution too.
So we know the solution.
It's not so essential.
Its purpose is to help you
learn and how to figure it out.
And beyond a certain
point, it's not
that instructive
in my experience.
Though sometimes the
fifteenth and a half hour
you suddenly have the great
insight and you learn a lot,
but most the time not.
And by the way the reading
is in [? Beer's ?] textbook
pages 258 to 311.
And there's also some nice
short readings by Professor
[? Brautz ?] that have been
posted, only a few pages long
but definitely worth a look.
Both on [? PPPs ?] and also
in ODEs and [? DAEs. ?]
So today what we're
going to talk about
is relaxation methods.
And we talked last time
about the shooting method.
So that's a good method.
At least one famous
numerical methods
book recommends you always
shoot first then relax.
So try the shooting method.
If it works, you're done.
If it doesn't work
for you, then you
may have to use a
relaxation method.
And we'll talk a bit now
about the relaxation methods.
And the general idea is
you're going to write your y--
which is an
approximation, it's not
going to be the real solution--
and you're going to try
to write that typically
as an expansion to
some basis functions.
So let's say the
nth component of y.
And then you're going to vary
these coefficients, the d's,
to try to make your solution
as good as possible.
And now we're talking
about different definitions
of what good is for the
solution for a problem.
And you have to be aware
that almost always, this
will not exactly solve the
differential equation system.
So it's always going to be
wrong everywhere, typically.
And you can get to
decide sort of--
if you wanted to be good
at some particular spot,
you can do something about that.
If you wanted to, on
average, be good in some way,
you can decide that.
And it's sort of how much
error you can tolerate.
And in general, you have to do
a finite sum of a finite basis
set.
For many, many ODE,
[? PPP ?] problems,
there's math proofs that
if-- and the limit is this
goes to infinity if you add an
infinite number of functions
here.
You can always make it work
to get the true solution.
But you can never afford
that so you're always
finite truncated basis
set is what you're using.
And so a lot of
the accuracy things
have to do with exactly
what functions you choose
and exactly how many of these
terms and sum you include.
But typically, these problems
will start from the beginning,
you'll say I'm only
going to include so
many, how big my computer is.
And so you're going to
be stuck with some error,
so that's just the way this.
Let's recall the
problem we have.
If we write it in the--
as a first order ODE
system, it's dy/dt--
well, there's some function
of dy/dt and y and t
that's equal to zero which
often can be written something
like this, dy/dt is equal
to an f [INAUDIBLE]..
Right?
And so if you plug in
this approximation for y,
then you'll get something here
that will be some g of t that's
generally not going
to equal zero,
but you would like
it to be zero.
If you put the true solution
in, you would get zero.
If you put your
approximate solution,
it is not going to be zero.
So you'll get g
of t and you want
this equal to zero for all t.
And then in addition, you
have boundary conditions.
And so you have boundary
conditions on the solution
and you want those
things to be satisfied.
And again, you can
write them in a form
that something has to be zero.
Often, you'll
exactly satisfy them.
So you'll choose
your solution to make
sure it satisfies the
boundary conditions
and it won't satisfy
in the domain.
It won't really satisfy
the differential equation.
That's the most
common thing to do.
But it could also be that it
doesn't satisfy the boundary
conditions either, but you
want to be close to satisfy
the boundary conditions.
We have to think
of how are we going
to judge if the solution
is accurate or not,
if our approximate
solution is good?
And from the way we wrote it,
we have our parameters, d.
These are numbers we can adjust.
And we're going to try to adjust
them to make the solution as
good as possible.
And now we just define
what a good means.
There are several definitions
of good that are widely used.
And one of them is
called collocation.
This is like option number one.
And that is you choose a set of
ts, of particular time points.
And for those
particular type points
you demand that g of the
time point is equal to zero.
So you're forcing the
residuals-- this is called
the residual, it's the error.
And you're forcing the error to
be zero at some particular time
points.
And generally between
the time points
it will not be equal to zero.
But you can pick your time
points and depending on which
ones you pick, you'll get a
slightly different optimal
choice of the d's.
Because the d's will
be adjusted to force
the residual to be zero at
your time points you pick.
So that's one option.
Another one is
called Rayleigh-Ritz.
And that one is you
minimize overall your d's.
The integral in t zero to t
final of the norm of g of t.
So this means you try
to make the average
of the square of that deviation
to be as small as possible.
So it's like sort of
like a least squares fit
kind of thing.
So that's another option.
And then a third
one that people use
a lot is called
Galerkin's Method.
And his method is you
choose some functions--
some of your basis
functions typically--
and you integrate them
with each of the elements
of the residual.
And you demand that that
has to be equal to zero.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
for [? this method, ?]
what do you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: The d's,
your coefficients.
And these ones, I
didn't write it out
but this g depends
implicitly on the d's,
so you can write it that way.
A lot of d's.
And so you optimize the
d's, you very the d's
to force g to be
zero at certain ts.
And this one also,
the g depends on d's.
And so you're going
to optimize the d's
to force this integral
equation to be satisfied.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
all changing d's?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
They're all changing d's.
And it's just trying to-- your
criterion, your error measure,
how do you measure or
what do you think is good?
You want to make something
small, some kind of error
small, but you
have to figure out
what are you going to
define your error to be.
And you'll get different
solutions depending
on which error measure you use.
Is this OK?
Now this one's pretty
straightforward.
I'm just going to write it down
a bunch of algebraic equations
that depend on my d's and
then I'm going to solve them.
And this looks a lot like
[? an f ?] [? solve ?] problem.
This is a Newton problem
or something like that.
So it's just some
algebraic equations.
Should be OK?
So that one you should be pretty
well set up to do right now.
Let's just think of how
many equations there are.
So we have-- say we have
our basis set yf t dni fit.
That's our basis set.
And this is a sum over
i equals one to say
the number of basis functions.
What do you want to call that?
N, sound good?
So we have n basis functions.
And so we have how
many unknowns here?
Maybe n's not good
because n's this one.
Let's call it something else.
k, OK.
All right?
In fact, I'll even
change this to k
too just to make life easier.
So there are how
many dnk's are there?
There's n where n
is the dimension,
the number of od's or the number
of components in y times k.
That's how many d's we got
that we're going to adjust.
We want to have an equal number
of equations and unknowns.
We have to have as
many equations as that.
So what equations do we got?
How many equations?
So if we just have
a ODE [? BBP ?]
we typically have n
boundary conditions.
So that many boundary
conditions because we
need one boundary condition
for each differential equation,
right?
One integration
constant for each one.
So we took an n
boundary conditions.
And then we have--
in collocation, we have however
many capital M time points
we chose.
So we have M n equations--
no, that's not right.
We have an equation like that
for every component of g.
So it's M times n equations
from the collocation.
Is that all right?
So just looking
at this, it looks
like we have n times
M plus one equations
and we have n times k unknowns
that we're trying to adjust.
And so therefore, this
says we should choose k
to be equal to M plus one.
So if we choose we want to say
we want 100 basis functions,
then we need 99 time points to
do collocations at it in order
to exactly determine everything.
Is that OK?
How many people
think this is OK?
OK.
He agrees.
It's OK.
The rest of you, no opinion.
This is like the American
political system.
Only 5% people vote.
Everybody else just
listens to Donald Trump.
So this is how many
equations we need.
Now sometimes people will
choose the basis functions
so that, say, some of the
boundary condition equations
might be satisfied
automatically.
And I'll talk a little bit
in a minute about cleverness
in choosing basis functions.
So one possible thing is you
can try to cleverly choose
basis functions so that no
matter what values of d's you
choose, you're always going to
satisfy some of the boundary
conditions.
And so long as you don't
get a full value of n
because some of these
boundary conditions
don't help you determine
the d's, any values
of d's will work.
And so in those cases, you need
a few-- might need another time
point or something.
Get some more equations.
So that's collocation.
And I think this should be
perfectly straightforward.
You just evaluate your y's.
You need to have your dy/dts.
You'll need them, because
they appear in g as well.
And they're just going to be
the summation over k [? of ?]
[? dnk ?] v prime k of t.
And so you choose
basis functions
that the analytical
derivatives of.
So now you know these answers.
And now you can evaluate
this at any time point tm.
So you evaluate
your time points.
You evaluate these guys
at your time points.
You plug them all into your
g expression over here,
and your force is equal to
zero, by varying the d's, right?
No problem.
So that's collocation.
That's pretty easy.
And because it's so easy, it's
kind of pretty widely used
as one way to go.
All it requires is that you
have to know the derivatives
of your basis functions.
In particular, doesn't
require any integrals.
When you see the
other methods, they're
going to involve integrals.
So we'll have to figure out
how we're going evaluate those.
So if you have
functions you don't
know how to integrate then
this is definitely the way
to go, to do collocation.
And if you use collocation
with enough points,
you're forcing the error
to be zero a lot of points,
then probably it won't get
that big in between the points.
At least you can
hope that I won't get
that big between the points.
And you can try it with
different numbers of points.
And different size
numbers of base
functions and see
what you can do.
See if it converges to
something, if you're lucky.
All right.
So that's one way to go.
And it's just f solve problem.
And all that's happening is
it's just forming a Dracovian
Matrix inside there.
Now, you still have to choose
which basis functions you want.
And there's a lot
of basis functions
you know that you know
the derivatives of.
So there's some issues here
about what choice is best.
And we'll talk a little
about that in a minute.
One thing you have
to watch out for,
is you don't want
your basis functions
to be linearly dependent
because then you'll end up
with indeterminate values a d.
Different sets of d's will
give you exactly the same y.
If these phi's-- if one of these
phi's is a linear combination
of other phi's in your set, then
you could have different values
of d's that would actually
correspond to exactly the same
y.
Because of that, when you a
Jacobian Matrix as part of it
your Newton solve,
the Jacobian's
going to be singular, and
then the whole thing's
not going to work.
So that's one thing
to watch out for.
And actually, it
doesn't really matter
if the functions are orthogonal
in the sense of being functions
orthogonal, it's really whether
the vector, vk evaluated tm,
if those are independent
of each other or not.
I feel like we talked about
this before, one time, yes?
Yes.
All right.
So anyway, as long as
the vk evaluate of tm,
if those things
are vectors which
are not linerally
dependent on each other,
this should work fine.
OK?
All right.
Now, really [INAUDIBLE].
This one here often gets
to be kind of messy.
Part of it is that inside
this norm of this vector,
it's square, so you end up
getting squares of your d's.
So, the whole
thing is definitely
non-linear in d to start with.
And then you have to be able to
evaluate all the integrals that
come up.
So this is really
sum over n, of g
and of td squared that
you're trying to integrate.
[INAUDIBLE] Right?
So, you have a lot of
these function squared.
You have to add them up.
You could do it, but the algebra
gets a little complicated.
So, this is not so
commonly done unless the g
has some special form that makes
the algebra a little easier.
But there's no reason you
can't do it in principle,
but it just is a little bit of
a mess because you get a lot
of integrals of cross
terms between the g's.
And in the d's inside there.
And so, not so commonly done.
Though one case where
it is done a lot
is in actually
quantum chemistry.
Methods called variational
methods in quantum chemistry
use real [INAUDIBLE] to
figure out the coefficients,
and like your orbitals,
and stuff like that.
So, it'd be certain methods.
But they've actually gone
out of favor recently.
So, you probably won't
use it that often.
But in the past,
that was a big deal.
Galerkin is used the
most of anything,
so let's talk about
that one for a minute.
Now, the concept, where does
this equation come from?
I guess that's one thing.
So maybe we can back
up and say, well,
where did the
collocation come from?
Collocation is actually
like a special version
of this where I choose, instead
of these basis functions,
I use delta functions.
So, if I integrated with
delta functions, t minus tm.
Another way to look
at the collocation
is demanding that the integral
of delta function t minus tm g
n a t dt is equal to zero.
OK.
So, now instead of
using delta functions,
I'm using these functions.
Basis functions.
So I don't know if it's
particularly obvious why
you'd use one or the other,
but anyway, you have a choice.
And any time you do this kind
of integral with some number
of functions, you get some
number of equations that can
help you determine the d's.
This particular choice
of the basis functions--
one way to look at it is,
you can say, well, suppose
my solution g g n,
suppose I could write this
as a sum of some different
expansion coefficients.
So I can relate this plus
OK, so, there's two terms.
One is the expansion of
the residuals in the basis
that I'm using, and
one is all the rest
going on to infinity
of all the other basis
functions in the universe.
And if I think my basis set
is very complete, that it kind
of cover all the
kinds of functions
I'm ever going to deal
with, both in y and in g,
in the residual, then this
would be a reasonable thing,
and you might expect
that this term-- if you'd
pick big K big enough,
this might be small.
So that's sort of
where the idea is.
So then, if I think
this is small,
then I want to make
sure I make this part as
close to accurate as possible.
And this condition is
basically doing that.
It's saying that I want the
[? error ?] to be orthogonal
to the basis functions,
in the sense that,
for two functions, the integral
of the two functions like this,
is like an inner product,
just like the inner product
between two vectors.
So I'm saying, like,
in the vector space,
in the function space
that I'm working in,
I don't want to have any error.
That's what this is saying.
But I'm going to have is that
there's other g terms which
are the rest over here.
These guys will not be
orthogonal to the first part.
Does that make sense?
So there's still some
error left, in my g.
But the part in here, I can
make a good [? answer. ?]
So that's where this equation
comes from conceptually.
All right.
And we'll come back-- when we
do least square [? setting, ?]
we'll come back
to that same idea.
So this is what the
equation looks like,
and the disadvantage of this one
is it involves some integrals.
And so you have to be able
to evaluate the integrals.
All right.
So that's the downside
of this function.
So cleverly choosing
using your basis functions
to make it easy to evaluate the
integrals is like the key thing
to make this a good method.
And just like we needed
analytical expressions
for the derivatives here, now
we need analytical expressions
for integrals.
That we're going to
get from this guy.
OK.
So, let's think about what basis
functions we can choose that
might make it easier to
evaluate the integrals.
Suppose we can
write g explicitly.
Like, this.
So, g is equal to d
gx dyn/dt minus f/n.
Suppose.
OK?
Then what integrals
am I going to get?
Well, dyn/dt is the sum of
the derivatives of the basis
functions, and y is
just this sum up there.
Some of the basis functions.
And so, I'm going
to have integrals
that look like this is like
I have an integral phi j
summation d phi prime.
No, k.
t.
dt.
That will be the integrals
from the first term.
And then I'll have minus some
integrals from the second term
here.
So, phi j fn ft y, where y
is the sum-- it's actually
like a matrix.
All right.
Because this y is a vector.
It's all the yns.
And so, the whole y vector
is d times the phi vector.
All right.
Where d's that big matrix.
The elements are
[? dnk. ?] And so,
if you cut these
integrals, this thing
here is a summation
of [? dnk. ?]
The integral of phi j.
Phi k prime.
And so, if you choose your
basis functions cleverly,
you might be able to know all
these integrals analytically.
OK?
But if you don't
choose them cleverly,
who knows what kind of horrible
mess you'll end up here.
All right.
Ideally, you really want to
get these all analytically
so you don't have to do
numerical integration.
As a loop inside, all
the rest of the work,
you're going to do
in this problem.
OK?
And then, these ones also,
now knowing something about
this is really
important or you may
have to do the numerical
integration here, because this
could be really a mess.
You have a lot of phis
inside some function, which
could be a non-linear
function of these guys.
And so, in principle this
could be really horrible.
So you may have to do numerical
quadrature for those guys.
All right.
OK, and so, if you do Galerkin's
method, a big part of that
is thinking ahead of time,
oh, what basis function am I
going to use?
How can I make a
basis function so I
can evaluate the
integrals easily,
and then I might have
a chance to do it?
All right, questions so far?
AUDIENCE: Phi j
PROFESSOR: Phi j.
Sorry, phi j of t.
Here, I'll get rid of the t's.
These are both functions of t.
You're integrating over t.
And these integrals
from t0 to to t phi.
Your domain.
All right.
Now in Galerkin's
method, in addition
to these integral
equations, I still
have the integrals,
the equations,
that the boundary conditions.
So I still have
some equations that
look like collocation equations
that are evaluated at tm.
Do I have that anywhere?
Nowhere.
I have an equation like this,
except it's not g, it's q,
it's the boundary
condition equations
have to be true at the
boundary conditions.
Right?
So they're the same as
before, q [? or just ?]
before qn of dy/dt
evaluated at tn y of tn.
tn.
This is equal to 0.
This is sort of the general way
to write a boundary condition.
And so there'll be some special
ends, the boundaries, where I
want to have extra conditions.
I'll get some
equations like this.
These have to be satisfied
in Galerkin's method as well
and they will not be integrals.
They are just that, tn.
And so in addition to the
integral equations, that you
have to solve over here, you
want these things to be zero
and you also want to satisfy
the boundary conditions.
So then, all these
methods, a big part of it
gets to be cleverness of a basis
function, a choice of basis
functions.
And there's kind of two
families of approaches.
So, one family is
global basis functions.
So basis functions that are
defined on the whole domain.
And there are special
ones, sines and cosines,
Bessel functions,
all these functions
inferred from your classes,
all the special functions.
And a lot of them, the integrals
are known for a lot of cases.
There might be special
tricks that make
the integrals easy to evaluate.
They can satisfy the boundary
conditions automatically.
And some of them, for
example, many of the problems
we have with like the heat
flow equation, so you have--
actually it won't be d.
I'm probably going
to get this wrong.
It's, like, kappa or alpha.
Which one is it?
Alpha.
Alpha d square of td, x
squared minus, there's
some source of heat that might
depend on the temperature,
and this has to be,
say, equal to zero.
Right, does this seem what
you've seen in classes before?
So this is a common one.
So, in this case, you might try
t to be a sum of, say, sines.
So [? dnk ?] sine of k
something something something.
In there, and the
cleverness of this
is that d squared
phi k dx squared is
going to be equal to
some number times phi k.
Because the second derivatives
of sines are also sines.
Right?
So all your
differentials will solve
and in fact, the derivatives
will be really simple.
Now, the q terms could
still be a horrible mess.
For example, this could be
an Arrhenius thing where's
the t's up in the exponent.
And then the whole
thing might be horrible.
Anyway.
But at least the differential
part is, like, super easy.
OK.
And you might have a boundary
condition say, at one end,
that dt/dx at someplace like d
final x final is equal to zero.
Right?
That might be like, you're
up against a x insulator.
Or something like that.
So, you don't have a heat flow.
So that would be a boundary
condition you might have.
And then, by cleverly choosing
your definition of the sines,
you could force that
all the sines satisfy
this derivative condition.
OK, so, rescale your coordinates
so that ends up with pi over 2,
an all sides of
everything and pi over two
is always zero, the
derivative, so you're good.
So, you can do some
clever trickiness
to try to make the
problem easier to solve.
And so, that's one whole
branch of these basis function
methods, is clever
basis functions
to match the special
problem you have.
OK?
So that's one option.
Then, the other option is
the non-clever approach,
where you just say, well,
I've got a computer.
Who cares about being clever?
Let's just brute force it.
All right.
And instead, you just want
to write a general method,
any problem you can solve.
And this is more or
less what COMSOL does.
And you're going to do it.
And so the distinction
here is that this kind
of thing, this sine function,
has a value everywhere, all
across the domain.
So this is kind of
like a global function.
OK?
And the alternative
is to do local basis.
Try to have basis
functions that are only
defined in little tiny areas.
And then, at least when I
integrate the integrals,
I don't have to integrate
over the whole range.
I don't have to have
to integrate right
around my little basis function.
So, this global basis function--
this is sort of similar to what
we're doing, interpolation?
Do you remember you could
use high order polynomial
to interpolate, or you
could alternatively
do a little piecewise
interpolations,
say, with straight lines
between your points.
And, you know, it's
not so clear, actually,
which would be the
best way to do it.
Or maybe you want to
do some combination.
Do little parabolas
between little triples
of points, or something.
That might be a good
interpolation procedure.
It's the same thing here.
Some problems, you can find
a global basis set that works
great and you should use it.
In other problems
you might do better
to just break up the domain
in little tiny pieces
and then do simple little
polynomials or something
in those little domains.
All right.
So this is the global basis.
Let's see a local basis.
It's OK to delete this?
So, local basis functions.
A really common choice for
these guys are the b-splines.
And, in particular,
first order of b-splines
and these functions have
the shape phi phi k,
it looks like this.
So, at zero, all the
way up to ti minus 1.
Then it goes up to
one at ti, and then it
goes down to zero
again, and goes out.
OK.
So this function is a b-spline.
It's also called a tent function
because it looks like a tent.
Some people call
it a hat function.
I don't have a pointy head so it
doesn't look like a hat to me,
but they call it a hat
function so I guess
they must have hats like that.
And this is a very
common basis set.
And the nice thing about
this basis function
is, it's zero except in this
little tiny domain around it.
OK?
And it's the only basis
function in the whole set that
has a non-zero value of ti.
And so if you want the function
to equal something in ti,
it's going to be equal to
the coefficient of this basis
function, right?
Because we're going
to write y n of t
is equal to summation
[? dnk ?] phi k of t.
And so, if I really care
about yn evaluated at ti,
the only one basis function
this whole sum is going
to have a non-zero value there.
So that's going to
be equal to dn dnk, k
where this is the special k.
k prime matches up to ti.
OK, so there's one base
function that looks like this.
There's another one
over here that's
the one base center
on this point,
and there's another
one over here.
So on this point,
it's [INAUDIBLE]..
And I have as many basis
functions as I have points.
So this is like a way I
discretize the problem,
but I've kept my solution
as continuous function
because my y--
that's the sum of these guys--
has a value everywhere.
It's a continuous function.
The way this is written
it looks like it might not
be differentiable
at all the points
because it has all
these kinks, but there's
a clever trick you can do
to deal with the kinks.
So, actually, it's
not a problem.
AUDIENCE: So, for
these basis functions,
how would you define if
you had the boundaries?
Like t0?
PROFESSOR: So, you'll have a
basis function at the very end.
Suppose this is t0 here.
You have one like that.
OK, so it's just
a half of a tent.
Can you get a
[? sparse ?] d-matrix?
Yes.
So locality is really
good because it
makes the Jacobian matrix
sparse, the overall problem.
So, when I compute the
integrals of this thing,
for example, the integral of phi
i of t, phi i minus 1 of t dt,
this turns out to be equal
to 1 or 2 times ti minus ti
[INAUDIBLE].
No.
I take that back.
Just one half.
Just half.
So it is like a brilliant thing.
Is that right?
It does have a ti [INAUDIBLE],,
not a [INAUDIBLE]..
I'll have to double check.
Possibly including delta t.
I can't remember.
All right.
But the integrals
are very analytical,
and only certain
ones are non-zero.
So only one that the two is when
the two is differ by one unit,
do they have a
non-zero integral?
All the rest of
them are non-zeros.
So, when I write
down these equations,
I mean, many, many,
many, many zeros,
so it looks horrible when
I write Galerkin's method,
I get so many integrals, but
actually a zillion of them
are zero, and then there's
a bunch of special tricks
I can do that make it
even better than that.
OK?
So then, the Jacobian sparse.
So, that'll save you a lot of
time in linear algebra, which
allows you use a lot of points.
So, you can use a very large
basis set because you end up
with sparse Jacobians,
I mean, it's not
going to fill your memory
storing all the elements
in the Jacobian, even if the
number of points is very large.
And also, there's vast numerical
solution methods for those.
So that's the idea of this.
I guess should we try to
carry one of these out?
You guys are [INAUDIBLE]
trying to do a lot of algebra
on the board?
Do you think I can do
the algebra on the board?
That's the real question.
All right.
Should I do it for
collocation, or you
guys confident you
can do collocation?
You're all right
with collocation?
You're fine with collocation.
Great.
OK.
So we'll just go
right into Galerkin.
So, Galerkin.
That way, we use a local basis.
So, most of the equations we
have to solve are this type.
Phi j t times the residual
function of summation [? dnk ?]
phi k prime.
Summation [? dnk ?]
of phi k and t.
Is equal to zero.
All right, we have a lot
of equations like that.
We're trying to
find the d's that
are going to force all
these integrals to be zero.
OK?
So we have a lot of different
j's we're going to try.
We want this to be
true for all the n's.
And then we're going to adjust
these [? dnk's ?] to try
to force this to be zero.
All right?
That's the main problem.
And then, on top
of this, there's
some equations with
boundary conditions.
So, now we have to look
at what the form is.
If the form is, oh, I erased
it, if I can make this explicit
in the derivatives, which
I can do very often,
for example, this could
be dyn/dt minus [? fm. ?]
So then, dyn/dt is just this.
And then I'll have another term,
[? fm, ?] which will depend
on that [INAUDIBLE].
And so the integral
phi j, and I'll just
remind you that phi j
is not equal to zero.
If tj minus 1 is
less than tj plus 1.
All right.
That's the only places
where my local basis
function is non-zero.
That's where the tent is.
And all the rest of it's zero.
So when I have this
integral, originally have it
t0 to t-final, but
actually I could replace
this with tj minus 1 to tj.
And it's just the same.
Because of all the integral
outside that domain is zero.
Because this function is zero.
All right?
So at least I have a
small little domain
to do the integral over.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] tj?
PROFESSOR: tj plus 1.
Thank you.
Yes.
Plus 1.
Is that all right?
OK.
So, I have this
integral, and then
I have this times the
derivative term, so it's dnk
dk prime minus the same
integral, j minus 1.
J plus 1.
Phi j sorry [? fm ?]
[INAUDIBLE] summation of dn.
k phi.
k [INAUDIBLE] t.
OK.
Now, this derivative
of phi k, well, I just
told you what it was.
It's just like the
[INAUDIBLE] set functions.
So, this integral,
you'll know analytically.
Like, it's either 0 or it's 1/2.
Maybe minus 1/2.
Whatever, but it's
nothing complicated,
and you'll just know
it right off the bat.
So this is all
that can be known.
And sparse.
It's only going to be when k is
equal to j minus 1 or j plus 1
that this will be non-zero,
and all the rest of it
would be zero.
OK?
So, that's mostly zeros.
This one over
here, in principle,
I have quite a huge sum
here, k equals 1 to k,
where I have all
my basis functions,
which is all my points where
I put my little tents down.
So I have a domain and
I've parked a lot of tents
all on the domain, that's
my basis functions.
And I'm trying to
figure out, sort of,
how high the tent poles are.
On all those tents.
And my tunnel functions, the
sum of all the heights of those
tents.
OK?
But this guy is only non-zero
in this little domain,
and these guys, most of them
are zero in that domain,
because they're mostly tents
that are far away from where
my special tent phi j is.
OK, so I'm going
to draw a picture.
Here's the domain
from t0 to t-final.
Over here is my tent
corresponding to phi j,
which is centered around tj.
Hence, this function.
And then, these guys
are all the other tents.
There's a tent here,
there's a tent like this,
there's another tent like
this, another tent like this.
All these tents.
Those are all the
basis functions
starting from k
equals 1 and going up.
All of these guys are zero in
this domain because they all
have zero tail.
So, almost all of these,
the f's doesn't really
pick up anything from
any of those guys
in the domain I care about.
The only domain I care about
is this domain right here.
And this whole sum is all zero
except for a few special k's
when k is equal to j
minus 1, j, or j plus 1.
So I only have to worry
about three terms.
The inside contributing to
the y in the region of t
that I care about.
All right?
So, when I want to compute
the Jacobian with respect
to d, the only terms here
where the Jacobian's going
to be non-zero are for d
I have a Jacobian, which
is the derivative of
this whole thing, ddd nk.
Right?
And that's only non-zero if
k is equal to j minus 1 j,
or j plus 1.
You guys see that?
How many people do not see this?
How many people are lying?
This is a really important
concept for the locality,
so this is the advantage
of a local basis,
that the Jacobian
will turn out to be
really sparse because it's only
non-zero in this special case.
And you might have
1,000 points, 1,000
of these little tent, 1,000
basis functions in the sum.
But only three of
them are non-zero.
For four each n.
So, actually, it's 3 times n.
[INAUDIBLE] non-zero.
Is that all right?
Because it just
depends on the k.
Three of the ks are non-zero.
There's 1,000 of these
guys [INAUDIBLE]..
Yep.
So that's the big
trick of locality.
And then, also, because
these integration ranges
are so small, because you
choose your points really finely
spaced, then you might get
away with simple polynomial
expansions of f, for example.
Around the points, or
[INAUDIBLE] expansions,
there are all kinds
of little tricks.
Or you could even do quadrature
and determine some points,
do a [INAUDIBLE] quadrature
to evaluate the integral.
But you only need a few
points, because you know
it's a little tiny range of dt.
And you would hope that
you've chosen so many fees, so
many time points, that
your function doesn't
change much from one
time point to the next.
So, more or less, first
order is constant.
Your function's
constant with respect
to t in this little tiny
domain, and then maybe
has a little slope.
And then, if you're
really being fancy,
you might be able to
put a parabola on it.
But it's not going
to change that much.
If it's changing a
lot, that's telling you
you don't have
enough time points
and you should go back and put
some more basis functions in.
And then you can get
a good [INAUDIBLE]..
Because what we're,
really doing here
is we're using this basis set.
If I add up these guys,
what I'm really doing
is piecewise linear
interpolation
between all the points.
So I'm approximating
my y versus time.
It's going to look like this.
All right.
It's piecewise
linear, because that's
the only thing you can
make from adding up
a bunch of straight
line segments.
A bunch of tents is a
bunch of straight lines.
And so this is what the
approximate function is.
Well, you can see,
this is really bad
if these functions are too
different from each other.
But if they're all like this--
and you think,
well, maybe it's not
so bad to use piecewise linear.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
confused at where
we're using [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Inside
[? f ?] solve, what
is trying to solve
for the d's, it's
solving each of this giant set
of the equations, a whole lot
of equations like this, they
all come in to a gigantic f.
That's the f of d that need
to make equal to to zero.
And so, I'm
[? burying ?] the d's,
I need the Jacobian
of that gigantic f.
Now, the problem,
because it's gigantic,
I need a lot of points, a
lot of closely spaced points
to make my function look smooth.
That means the number of base
functions is really huge.
So the Jacobian principle
is huge number squared.
I have 1,000 points, say,
discretizing my domain.
And then it's 1,000
by 1,000 Jacobian.
It might be really hard to solve
it, or cost a lot of CPU time,
or use a lot of memory.
But, fortunately, almost
all the elements are zero.
So, it's like, has a
sparsity of 0.3% or something
is the occupancy.
So, it's almost all
completely sparse,
and therefore you can solve
it even though it's gigantic.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
basis function [INAUDIBLE]
the Jacobian [INAUDIBLE]
should be [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: We're
trying to find d,
so we're really trying
to solve a problem that's
f of d is equal to zero.
That's our fundamental
problem we're trying to solve.
We're doing Galerkin.
We have something equal to
zero, and it depends on d.
And we're trying
to find the d's.
So this is really the function
we're trying to solve.
In order to evaluate
the elements in this,
we have to compute a
whole bunch of integrals
with the Galerkin method.
So that's the complexity.
But the basis functions,
we know what they are.
We've pre-specified them.
So, the whole question
is just what the d's are.
And the d's get multiplied
by a whole lot of integrals.
Is this all right?
I think I may have
misunderstood the question.
So you have f of
d is [INAUDIBLE],,
so therefore we probably want
to know j with respect to d.
OK.
Time ran out before
clarity was achieved.
We'll try to achieve clarity
on Wednesday morning.